wir wollen jetzt noch einmal live in die
bilder schon unser kolleginnen des
merkens ist nämlich auch vor ort hier
vom berliner reichstag und gibt diese
bilder erreichen ist wie im leben
findest du dich stimmen gerade vor ort
ja wir können die kapuze deutlich weiter
vom reichstag auf sie diese vom
reichstag bewegen
die war eigentlich gesperrt mit verbund
mit demonstranten eröffnet und ich halt
noch mal oben dann können wir das essen
besser sehen
ok jetzt bin ich mit eingeklemmt also
müssen wir haben eine kleine gruppe von
demonstranten die jetzt von der polizei
eigentlich schüsse und ich gehe davon
aus dass man versucht diese vor dem
weißen wieder zu räumen
die von der bühne gibt entsprechende
hinweise an die wirtschaftsteilnehmer
bisher geht so ich habe noch keine
aggression bestätigt haben sich menschen
auf wie geschätzt aber noch kein einsatz
von irgendwelchen besonderen griffen
oder reizgas bisher geht das hier noch
nie ist deine einschätzung es ist es für
eine gruppe von demonstranten es scheint
sich ja um eine splittergruppe zur
handel denn nochmal machen sie sich ja
nicht auf dem weg zu der kundgebung am
großen stern
welches thema verfolgen sie was kannst
du dort aufgreifen
also von den symbolen die ich sehen
konnte ist es eine balance aus menschen
die ans deutsche wald glauben die
anonymous glauben die
verschwörungstheorie in
unterschiedlicher couleur glauben bevor
die gatter ausgerissen wurden habe ich
nach hinten an schon der titel gesehen
haben gerade an
ich habe jetzt gerade aus den augen
verloren aber es ist eine mensch
unterschiedlichster
demonstrationsteilnehmer und ich muss
gestehen ich konnte nicht herausfinden
bisher
wer hier federführend jetzt hast du denn
die möglichkeit dass ihnen gerade gesagt
und befindet sich ja in diesem kessel
der polizei mit einem der demonstranten
zu sprechen vielleicht in erfahrung zu
bringen worum es ihnen geht
entschuldigung da wie sie tragen sie
sich hier ein trip
ich komme von bild live wir machen eine
live kann man von wild light wir machen
möchten ok also ich habe glaube ich ein
wahnsinns chance war das sind menschen
die ich lieben könnte auch müssen auf
die schnelle jemanden zu finden der
leser kann befreien steht das
komme ich gerade nicht bereit wir
versuchen mich einfach so weiterhin wir
werden auch weiterhin noch zu hier
schalten wenn wir im studio ist aber
auch noch weiterhin max kieffer bild
reporter und auch polizei experte
vielleicht kannst du diese situation
auch noch mal für uns bewerten wie kann
sich diese situation demonstranten sind
eigene kasse scheint jetzt ruhig zu sein
aber es kommt natürlich auch immer
wieder zu aggressiven rufen wie kann man
diese situation überhaupt das auflösen
also ich glaube die zeit ist gerade
genau richtig gesagt das sind rechte
splittergruppen die da gerade sich
versammelt haben wir sehen die
reichskriegsflagge menschen die vorher
attila hildmann zugehört haben von dem
wir wissen das ist dann der harte kern
eher harte rechte kern auf dieser
bewegung ist und daher liegt es an der
polizei die situation zu deeskalieren
sicherlich zuerst wir sehen uns erst mal
an sie einfach nur sozusagen diesen
diesen diese demo gruppe umschlossen
stellen sicher dass er nicht
weiterlaufen können stellen sicher dass
vielleicht nicht noch weitere
demonstranten dazu kommen können und
dann wird man die menschen freundlich
bitten zu gehen wenn sie das nicht tun
wenn wir sehen wann und wie die
polizeiführung dann entscheidet